[Musica]
quando mi sono avvicinato ai social
network
ho pensato che avrei capito meglio la
tecnologia che sta alla loro base in
realtà quello che credo di avere capito
meglio in questi dieci anni di lavoro
sui social sono le persone gli esseri
umani
i social network sono importanti
strumenti di comunicazione
se ci pensate bene noi comunichiamo
durante tutta la nostra vita in continuo
anche quando siamo da soli abbiamo
bisogno di parlare fra noi stessi o di
pensare la comunicazione e vita nella
vita reale più semplice sui social
network la comunicazione la nostra
esistenza
c'è quando noi postiamo per questo dico
digito ergo sum e le conversazioni si
stanno spostando si spostano dalla vita
reale alla vita digitale avvengono
online in maniera significativa io mi
ricordo quando ero bambino e andavo a
fare la spesa con mia mamma quanta
conversazione nel passare da un negozio
all'altro
adesso faccio la spesa alla domenica
mattina online e se voglio parlare con
qualcuno e voglia di discutere alle
volte mi sposto sui social network e se
abbiamo qualcosa di importante da dire i
social network possono essere il posto
giusto
sappiamo che siamo quasi a 4 miliardi di
persone che hanno connettività online
quindi se abbiamo dei messaggi
importanti da lanciare i social possono
essere un posto in cui troviamo un
audience un pubblico che è interessato
ad ascoltarci social network parliamo di
facebook parliamo di twitter quali più
generalisti
in realtà i social network sono molto
vari e declinabili a seconda anche delle
attitudini degli utenti c'è chi
costruisce contenuti e li condivide e
chi usufruisce di contenuti e chi fa
entrambe le cose
e allora instagram per le fotografie e
youtube per i video e così via
l'opinione pubblica sta incominciando a
discutere significativamente online un
esempio che a me piace molto che voglio
riportarvi a quello di eni durante una
puntata di report report un programma
rai
dedicato proprio a eni decide di tenere
allerta attivo il proprio social media
team quindi ci immaginiamo un modo su
twitter di fare informazione
complementare o controinformazione
mentre i cittadini guardavano la
televisione potevano fare domande a eni
su twitter ricevendo delle risposte
io sono un ricercatore anche per me sta
cambiando il modo di lavorare
l'unione europea i finanziatori ci
chiedono di non passare tutto il tempo
chiusi nel nostro laboratorio ma di
imparare a valorizzare i risultati della
ricerca e la carta europea del
ricercatore ci dice che dobbiamo farlo
generando e trasferendo e condividendo
tecnologia i brevetti sono un esempio ma
un esempio molto interessante è quello
di imparare a comunicare i risultati ai
cittadini europei imparare a comunicare
la scienza per migliorare la percezione
dei ricercatori e della ricerca e
contemporaneamente fare cultura
scientifica
i ricercatori diventano importanti in
questo i dati che vi mostro sono dati di
un sondaggio ipsos mori del 2014 fatto
in gran bretagna come rappresentativa
della dell'europa adesso pensando alla
black city insomma non sappiamo quanto
sia veramente rappresentativa ma i dati
sono importanti e significativi ci
dicono che la maggior parte degli
intervistati ritiene che i mass media
sensazionali zino la scienza cioè non
facciano un racconto etico dei
ricercatori e della ricerca ma tendono a
attrarre visualizzazioni ad attrarre
elettori mentre dicono un'altra cosa
molto importante che oltre il 90 per
cento crede che noi ricercatori siamo le
persone giuste per raccontare a voi a
tutti la ricerca le modalità ed i
risultati
i social network sono strumenti
potentissimi sono in grado di
influenzare la distribuzione
dell'informazione
questa mappa ci mostra i principali
social network nel mondo
vedete che la gran parte e blu blu
significa facebook facebook significa
tante cose significa facebook instagram
whatsapp messenger un'enorme rete di
comunicazione sociale diffusa come
vedete in gran parte del mondo
e allora già nel 2015 succede una cosa
molto interessante
succede che le testate online delle
riviste che sono nate in maniera
cartacea corriere della sera repubblica
sono ancora prime come numero di accessi
ma piano piano e neanche tanto piano
piano in realtà arrivano i nativi
digitali city news e fan page ad esempio
che utilizzano i social network come
volano per la diffusione dei propri
contenuti
una cosa che fa specie vedere ansa la
principale agenzia di stampa italiana
incastrata tra due nativi digitali i
social network sono anche delle
piattaforme pubblicitarie e quindi hanno
pesanti implicazioni psicologiche
sociologiche ed economiche tante volte
quando ci sono notizie negative
associate ai social network sentite
incolpare i social in cyber bullismo le
fake news
in realtà non è così i social utilizzati
male possono favorire certi
comportamenti che però sono
comportamenti connaturati all'uomo
negli anni settanta del secolo scorso
philip zimbardo fece un esperimento
molto importante l'esperimento
carcerario di stanford prese delle
persone che avevamo deciso di
partecipare le mise in un finto carcere
e tolse loro la la propria individualità
dividendoli in gruppi un gruppo di
carcerati è un gruppo di guardie e in
quel caso
l'esperimento fu fermato dopo pochi
giorni per la violenza che si sviluppò
in questo carcere simulato dimostrò
questo che quando noi non operiamo
secondo la nostra responsabilità
individuale le dinamiche di operazione
in gruppo sono diverse e le connotazioni
spesso sono negative aggressività
crudeltà ora pensate ai social su alcuni
social possiamo essere anonimi possiamo
agire attraverso uno pseudonimo e
operare per gruppi politici sportivi e
allora vedete che possono favorire certi
comportamenti che già negli anni
settanta del secolo scorso quando
internet non esisteva
erano ben identificabili spesso vi
dicono i social network contengono
spontaneità e immediatezza
in realtà le grandi campagne di
comunicazione social sono molto studiate
dai ricercate a tavolino
e allora quando siamo sui social cosa
succede abbiamo una rete sociale di
persone i nostri amici la nostra rete è
questa rete
è bella ma contemporaneamente una bolla
e una bolla informazionale perché le
persone che selezioniamo ci assomigliano
sono amici magari sono compagni di
scuola hanno il nostro livello culturale
la nostra estrazione sociale rischiamo
di vedere soltanto una parte delle
notizie di confermarci tra noi che sono
il punto di vista giusto l'unico punto
di vista che esista quindi vanno
utilizzati
tenendo conto che c'è molto altro oltre
a quello che vediamo danari è lì che è
un economista comportamentale fa una
domanda dice come una mela marcia può
influenzare le altre mele di un barile
e noi possiamo portarla ai social
network e dire se una persona che
all'interno della nostra rete si
comporta in maniera non corretta non
etica ci influenza e la risposta dei
suoi esperimenti e ci influenza molto se
è una persona considerata in group
cioè se è una persona considerata
appartenente al nostro gruppo sociale
mentre se è una persona out group
non che non riconosciamo come del nostro
gruppo sociale viene più che altro a
stigmatizzata non viene presa di
ispirazione e allora dobbiamo fare molta
attenzione anche a questo
una cosa molto bella dei social network
e la bidirezionalità se pensate ai mass
media sono sordi parlano radio tv stampa
ma non ascoltano i social network ci
permette di raccontare qualche cosa ma
contemporaneamente di sentire catturare
le istanze delle persone che ci seguono
e allora anche per noi ricercatori
questa cosa diventa importante perché la
ricerca innovazione responsabile
richiede di raccontare le nostre
attività ai cittadini alle persone
interessate ma anche di catturare le
loro istanze per indirizzare in maniera
armonica le attività di ricerca e allora
dal basso si può parlare
e allora le persone che prima non
avevano parola possono dire e quando tim
month premio nobel per alcuni
esperimenti sul ciclo cellulare alcuni
dati sul ciclo cellulare rilascia questa
dichiarazione viene attaccato dalle
ricercatrici femminili dalle donne lui
cosa dice dice se in laboratorio ci sono
uomini e donne succedono tre cose tu ti
innamori di loro loro si innamorano di
te poi tu le critiche ai loro piano
per cui sarebbe meglio avere laboratori
separati gli uomini da una parte le
donne dall'altra e le ricercatrici si
arrabbiano molto fanno partire una
campagna social destruct in glee sexy e
l'astag e ironizzano addirittura sono
sarcastiche nei confronti di questa
dichiarazione
pochi giorni dopo tim hunt si dimette
dall'università in cui insegnava la
royal society lascia contestualmente una
dichiarazione dicendo che è molto
importante
rimuovere tutte le discriminazioni per
l'accesso al mondo della ricerca
quando parlate di qualcosa di importante
arriva a qualcuno di solito che mi dice
ma una no le cose non sono come dici tu
so io come sono questo si chiama effetto
dan kneen kruger
queste dunque si due studiosi
dimostrarono che noi abbiamo una
percezione di quello che sappiamo
falsata da un byas cognitivo meno
sappiamo di un argomento più tendiamo a
ritenersi esperti su quell'argomento e
allora c'è una conversazione su internet
che parla di malattia e arriva un utente
e dice questa malattia sicura col
bicarbonato bio
io lo provo e con me funziona è un altro
utente chiede che cos'è il bicarbonato
bio e lì ci si accorge di essere in
pieno effetto dan kneen kruger la
definizione di bicarbonato viene copiata
da wikipedia e per quanto riguarda il
bio l'utente risponde è bio sarà quello
purificato dall acqua non inquinata
il bicarbonato e un prodotto di sintesi
non è un prodotto che si purifica
dall'acqua stava consigliando una cura
senza sapere nemmeno quello di cui stava
parlando
i nuovi media possono avere impatto più
grande ancora dei mass media sulla
società civile
un esempio è quello del 2016 il virus
roberto burioni viene invitato un
virologo dell'università vita salute
milanese a parlare di vaccini quando
lascia lo studio è arrabbiato a
disappunto torna a casa scrive un post
su facebook e racconta perché non era
contento di come era stata svolta la
trasmissione che riteneva di non aver
avuto abbastanza tempo per parlare per
spiegare per discutere la trasmissione
fa un milione e 280 mila spettatori
secondo i dati auditel
il primo a posti roberto burioni fa
oltre 2 milioni di lettori
la settimana successiva viene modificato
il palinsesto e vengono dati 40 minuti
circa a burioni per parlare di faccini
in studio la comunicazione social
sfrutta dei meccanismi particolari punta
molto sul engagement e sull'emozione
sull'emozionalità sull'immagine e questo
lo vediamo anche sempre parlando di
vaccini quando agisce unicef unicef fa
dei post molto razionali ma accanto ai
post razionali fa post come questi molto
emozionali ci fa vedere bambini malati
di poliomielite nel 1937 se non ricordo
male comunque il secolo scorso in un
polmone d'acciaio per la respirazione
assistita ci fa vedere qualcosa che noi
non possiamo vedere piumati e importante
tenere presente
e allora parliamo di emozione parliamo
di emotività
parliamo di empatia e gli esperti ci
dicono una cosa molto importante ci
dicono attenzione perché ogni volta che
comunicate facendo una mediazione
attraverso il computer e quindi il
computer ma anche i nostri cellulari i
social network spegnete l'empatia perché
non vedete le persone con cui state
parlando perché non vedete le reazioni
che provocate nel vostro interlocutore
piacere e soddisfazione sicurezza dolore
e questo ci rende meno empatici ci rende
più aggressivi e ci fa sentire protetti
da quello schermo di vetro che filtra i
sentimenti positivi e negativi che siamo
in grado di suscitare nelle persone
allora sherry turkle racconta in uno dei
suoi libri
questa storia dei robot sociali a cui
cerchiamo di dare empatia questo
cucciolo di foca molto empatico un
piccolo robot che sente la direzione
della voce e sensibile al tatto e questa
donna in una casa di cura lasciata dal
figlio lì nella casa di cura perché non
andavano più d'accordo che empatizza con
il robot e parlando con il robot
trasferisce le proprie sensazioni propri
sentimenti dicendo è sarai triste sarà
un momento triste oggi è una giornata
così e cherie tarbal guarda da fuori
dice una cosa molto importante questa
donna era completamente sola il figlio
l'aveva lasciata e noi persone l'avevamo
abbandonata un robot non può capire
questo tipo di dolore
questa empatia simulata nascita dolore
morte non sono cose comprensibili da una
macchina per come sono compra
sensibili a noi e quindi quello che
dobbiamo ricordarci e che i social
network possono essere uno strumento
veramente grandioso per noi ricercatori
sono la possibilità di costruire
contenuti come noi desideriamo che siano
costruiti per raccontarvi realmente
quello che facciamo tutti i giorni in
positivo e in negativo le difficoltà e
le frustrazioni fanno parte di questo
contemporaneamente possiamo anche essere
editori di noi stessi quindi decidere le
modalità con cui pubblichiamo i
contenuti e questo capite che è uno
strumento incredibile una potenza
veramente notevole quello che dobbiamo
ricordarci ogni volta che utilizziamo
questo strumento e che dall'altra parte
dello schermo ci sono delle persone che
hanno delle paure e delle speranze delle
aspettative esattamente come noi
esattamente come tutti voi soltanto
ricordandoci questo in ogni interazione
in ogni post in ogni possibile atto
comunicativo faremo in modo che i social
network siano una grandissima occasione
da non mandare sprecata grazie
[Musica]